.
GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HAPPY THURSDAY, EVERYONE, AND
WELCOME TO "PERINO!!" WITH TWO!
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY WAY PAST MY BEDTIME,
WE BEGIN THE WAY ALL GREAT
FOX NEWS SHOWS BEGIN, WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE ARE REPORTING TONIGHT ON A
MISSING PERSON PAID 79-YEAR-OLD
CAUCASIAN MALE IDENTIFIES AS WHO
AND HUH,
OCCASIONALLY CALLS OTHERS JACK.
LAST SEEN IN DELAWARE.
MAYBE THE BASEMENT.
WEARING KHAKIS, BUTTON-DOWN,
DARK AVIATORS, A MASK DANGLING
OFF HIS EAR.
CARRYING THE NUCLEAR FOOTBALL.
HE ANSWERS TO THE NAME OF THE
COMEBACK KID AND THE BIG GUY,
A.K.A. YOUR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
ALSO GOES BY SCRANTON JOE OR
BRANDON.
IF YOU REALLY WANTED HIS
ATTENTION, YOU CAN SAY, HEY, WHO
WANT SOME ICE CREAM COME HE'LL
COME WANDERING AROUND TO YOUR
DOOR.
THE MEDIA IS SEARCHING FOR HIM
HIGH AND LOW, MOSTLY LOW.
STRANGE, CONSIDERING JUST LAST
WEEK THEY TOLD US THAT AFTER A
STRING OF BIG WINS, THE
PRESIDENT WAS ON A ROLL, HIS
STRETCH OF BAD LUCK WAS BEHIND
HIM, HIS POLL NUMBERS HAD HIT
ROCK BOTTOM.
LIKE A LINE OF PARMESAN CHEESE
UNDER HUNTER'S NOSE, THERE WAS
NOWHERE TO GO BUT UP.
[APPLAUSE]
VIA INFLATION REDUCTION I WAS
GOING TO TURN HIS PRESIDENCY
RIGHT AROUND?
I GUESS WHEN YOUR EKG FLAT LINES
TWICE A WEEK, ANYTHING LOOKS
LIKE A BUMP.
LOOK AT THESE HEADLINES RIGHT
HERE.
THIS ISN'T NEW FOR THEM.
THEY BEEN HIGHLIGHTING THIS ALL
OF AUGUST.
>> DON'T LOOK NOW, PEOPLE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN SLEEPY JOE HAS
HIMSELF A PRETTY FAT STACK OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> THIS IS A BIG DEAL!
>> THIS IS HUGE AND I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW BIG
THIS IS.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY SUCCESSFUL TWO
YEARS LEGISLATIVELY.
>> BIG VICTORY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> HE'S ACTUALLY INTERRUPTING
HIS VACATION AND FLYING BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE JUST FOR THIS
BILL SIGNING.
>> Dana: REALLY BIG DEAL.
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT,
LIKE "THE PLUS" BY GREG GUTFELD.
[LAUGHTER]
AND NO ONE IS BUYING THAT IT'LL
REDUCE INFLATION.
THIS SHAMELESSNESS FROM THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
IF WE COULD JUST CHANGE THE NAME
OF THE RECESSION, CONVINCE THEM
THAT DESPITE THE RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES THEY ARE PAYING,
INFLATION IS ACTUALLY 0%.
THE BILL WILL RAISE TAXES ON
PEOPLE MAKING AS LITTLE AS
$10,000 A YEAR IN ORDER TO BUY
MAKE ELECTRIC CARS FOR FAMILIES
WHO ARE MAKING $300,000.
THE MEDIA CLAPPED ALONG AND
WROTE THEIR IMMEDIATE COMEBACK
KID STORIES BUT I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THE SEQUEL: "RETURN TO THE
BASEMENT."
IN HIS OWN BASEMENT...
[APPLAUSE]
YOU KNOW, BETWEEN SOBS AND BITES
OF DOORDASH, HE'S ALREADY EATEN
THREE DRIVERS.
EATING FAMILIES, PAYING THE
HIGHEST IN 40 YEARS IN GROCERY
AND FOOD, IT'S SO EXPENSIVE.
AND BIDEN IS FORGIVING THE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT OF SOON TO
BECOME WEALTHY DOCTORS AND
LAWYERS BECAUSE MAYBE HE'S GOT
PLENTY OF BOTH.
THESE ARE ALL SYMPTOMS OF THE
SAME PROBLEM.
THE LATINX GENDER ISSUES, THE
PAPER STRAWS, BORDER BUSES
DROPPING OF MIGRANTS AT A FOUR
COSTAR $700 A NIGHT HOTEL IN
NEW YORK CITY PERMEATING OVER
OUR NATION LIKE MONKEYPOX,
SEEPED INTO OUR DAILY LIVES LIKE
AN UNSIGHTLY STAIN ON AMERICA'S
NATIONAL CABLE CLOTH.
DEMOCRATS HAVE LET THEIR
NARROWEST SECTION OF ACTIVIST
TAKE LEADERSHIP CONTROL OF THE
PARTY AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
MODELED THEIR AGENDA AFTER IT.
THEIR FOCUS WENT FROM USA TO AOC
WITHIN TWO YEARS.
THAT'S MY BEEF WITH ALL THE
BIDEN COMEBACK STORIES.
DEMOCRATS JOINING OTHER
DEMOCRATS TO PASS A BILL TO
SPEND MONEY DOUBLING THE SIZE OF
THE IRS AND GIVING MONEY TO
CLEAN ENERGY COMPANIES?
THAT'S NOT AN ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
IT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING FOR THE
92% OF AMERICANS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT INFLATION.
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATS' BASE NOW.
7-20% OF THE COUNTRY THAT AGREES
ON THE FURTHEST LEFT NONSENSE.
AND THE MEDIA THAT TREATS THOSE
KIND OF DEALS LIKE THEY ARE
SOLVING THE CLIMATE CRISIS THEY
AREN'T REALLY IMPACTING AT ALL.
POINTLESS POLICY DESIGNED BY THE
FAR LEFT AND CHEERED ON
INVALIDATED BY THE FAR LEFT.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER DEM SELF
LICKING ICE CAN COME IN.
WHEN A REPORTER IS SENT TO
DESIGNERS IN THE MIDDLE AMERICA
TO SMALL TO SEE HOW THEY GOT SO
MUCH OF THE MIDTERMS WRONG, THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD CONSIDER
SENDING A FEW STAFFERS TOO.
DON'T WORRY, STAFFERS BUT YOU
WON'T GET HURT.
TRIGGERED?
MAYBE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU NEED.
DID YOU SEE THE MEME OF THE
"PAWN SHOP CLOSE WILL GUY
SAYING, BEST I CAN DO IS...
GAS PRICES ARE $2 HIGHER THAN IT
SHOULD BE.
BORDER IS A MESS.
WORRIED ABOUT UKRAINE, TAIWAN,
MIDDLE EAST.
KIDS HAVE BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL TWO
YEARS AND FACING GENUINE
CHALLENGES BY THE LEFT IS, BEST
WE CAN DO IS ELECTRIC CAR TAX
CREDIT, 87,000 WERE IRS AGENTS,
ILLEGAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT
CANCELLATION FOR HARVARD
LAWYERS, A SEMINAR ON
IDENTIFYING AS LATINX.
I'M TWO SPIRITED SO THE OTHER
SPIRIT WILL REPORT YOU TO HUMAN
RESOURCES.
MORE LIKE THE DEAD CAT BOUNCE
KID.
THE MEDIA TRIES TO PUT A SPIN ON
THIS THING.
HERE IS REUTERS.
BIDEN APPROVAL RISES TO 41%,
HIGHEST SINCE EARLY JUNE.
BIDEN APPROVAL RISES TO THE
HIGHEST IN TWO MONTHS BEAR
THAT'S LIKE SAYING YOUR HORSE
FINISHED LAST BUT HEY, AT LEAST
HE FINISHED.
[STIFLED LAUGHTER]
TAKE YOUR OPERATION SOMEWHERE
EVEN TO DR. JAIL.
[/]
THESE ARE THE NUMBERS THAT'LL
KEEP THE COMEBACK KID FROM
GETTING TOO FAR LIKE A SHOCK
COLLAR THEY PUT IN HIS
UNDERPANTS.
FROM THE LATEST NBC POLL, 84%
SAY THE U.S. IS HEADING INTO THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT ENDS BILL de BLASIO'S RUN
FOR CONGRESS.
LAST TIME WE SAW THIS MUCH
DISAPPROVAL, JERRY LEWIS MARRIED
HIS COUSIN.
WE'LL EXPLAIN THAT LATER, KAT.
DESPITE THE BIG COMEBACK,
SEVERAL DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE NOW
DISTANCING FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> IT IS WASHINGTON'S FAULT.
THEY SET THE RULES, WEAKENED OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN, WEAKENED
INFLATION.
>> I VOTED AGAINST IT.
I VOTED WITH TRUMP ON TRADE.
I DON'T ANSWER TO ANY POLITICAL
PARTY.
>> I WAS THE ONLY DEMOCRAT TO
VOTE AGAINST TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OR PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AGENDA.
>> I STOOD UP AGAINST HIM IN MY
OWN PARTY AND PUSH TO CUT THE
GAS TAX AND HIRE MORE POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> I LEARNED ABOUT PUBLIC
SERVICE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, NOT
WASHINGTON.
>> Dana: OTHERS ARE FINDING
REASONS TO WASH THEIR HAIR WHEN
THEY HEAR BIDEN IS COMING INTO
TOWN.
WHICH ONLY FORCES THEM TO WANT
TO SMELL IT MORE.
IT'S BEEN THE BIGGEST WAR SINCE
GOT
THE COMEBACK KID STORIES WERE
WRITTEN IN THE CAN COME OF THE
MEDIA LOVES THAT STORY LINE WHEN
IT'S BEING SAID ABOUT A
DEMOCRAT.
WHAT SAY YOU, JOE.
>> I DON'T NEED A COMEBACK.
I'M HERE, MAN BEAR I DON'T NEED
A COMEBACK.
I DO THINGS NOBODY ELSE DOES.
DID YOU EVER TRY FOLLOWING UP A
FLIGHT OF STAIRS?
YEAH.
HOW ABOUT FALLING OFF A BIKE
THAT'S NOT MOVING?
TRY IT.
DO IT, DO IT!
I GOT YOU, MAN.
I RECOVERED FROM THE COVID LIKE,
40 TIMES NOW.
I FEEL GREAT.
COME ON, MAN.
WHAT YOU MEAN COMEBACK?
YOU TALKING TO ME?
THAT'S AN HONEST QUESTION
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TALKING TO
ME I'M TALKING TO MYSELF AND I
DON'T DO THAT, JACK!
>> Dana: IT'S LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO HAS
PREWRITTEN OBITUARIES SO THEY
CAN BE THE FIRST TO HAVE 2,000
WORDS ON KEITH RICHARDS WHEN HE
PASSES AWAY.
IT'S LIKE HE MADE A DEAL WITH
SATAN.
YOU WILL LIVE FOREVER BUT YOU
LOOKED AT THE ENTIRE TIME.
MAYBE WHAT THE MEDIA DIDN'T
REALIZE IS THE COMEBACK KID
STORY ACTUALLY IS AN OBITUARY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S WHERE GOOD COMMON SENSE
POLICY HAS GONE TO DIE.
IN LIEU OF DONATIONS, SEND YOUR
TAXES.
IT LEAVES ALL OF THE REST OF US
IN THE MORNING, BUT JUST FOR TWO
MORE YEARS.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HE'S LIKE CAITLYN JENNER.
PEOPLE USED TO CALL HIM FATHER
READ FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JONATHAN MORRIS!
HE'S A TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW
BECAUSE THE AUDIENCE IS USUALLY
A SLEEPY ACTOR, WRITER, COMEDIAN
JAMIE LASALLE.
HE IS THE SMARTEST PERSON EVER
TO LEAVE TEXAS FOR NEW YORK.
THE HOST OF "LAWRENCE JONES
CROSS-COUNTRY" SATURDAY NIGHTS,
LAWRENCE JONES.
AS THE MOST PROMINENT WOMAN ON
LATE-NIGHT TV, SHE INSPIRED ME
WHEN I GREW UP.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
THE MEDIA, THEY TRIED TO
CELEBRATE JOE.
THE LADIES, THEY SAY THIS IS
HUGE, THIS IS BIG.
DO THEY NOT REALIZE HE'S MAKING
INFLATION WORST?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
IT'S QUITE SAD.
I LOVE MY DALLAS COWBOYS.
I ROOT FOR THEM EVERY TIME, EVEN
IF I KNOW THEY ARE GOING UP AND
THEY END BACK UP LOSING THEIR
THAT'S WHERE THE MEDIA IS RIGHT
NOW.
YOU HAVE A WHOLE GROUP OF PEOPLE
ON THE SIDELINES SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS HEADING THE WRONG
DIRECTION, JUST TURN AROUND.
YOU CAN MAKE SOMETHING UP ABOUT
THIS PRESIDENCY.
I JUST DON'T THINK THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF IS LISTENING FOR THE
ONLY PEOPLE HE'S TRYING TO
PLEASE ARE THE PROGRESSIVES.
PROBLEM IS THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
OF THEM TO GET HIM TO VOTE TO
GET THEM ACROSS TO ANOTHER TERM.
IT'S PRETTY SAD BUT MAYBE THEY
SHOULD SPEND TIME IN THE DINER'S
LIKE I DO EVERYTHING THE DAY, GO
TO THE BARBERSHOPS OF AMERICA.
WHEN THE WHITE DINERS AND THE
BLACK BARBERSHOPS ARE SAYING THE
SAME THING, YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM.
>> Dana: IT'S A GOOD
BAROMETER.
YOU NEED TO PATENT THAT ONE.
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS UP IN
ALASKA?
>> NO.
I'M JUST HEARING ALL THIS NOW.
YEAH.
AM I LIVING IN AN ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE?
THE WAY THEY SPIN EVERYTHING?
YOU CAN'T SAY GAS PRICES ARE LOW
IF THEY WERE TOO HIGH TO BEGIN
WITH, RIGHT?
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS MARRIED MY
WIFE WOULD ALWAYS GO, WE'VE GOT
TO BUY THIS THING FROM PIER ONE.
50% OFF.
I WOULD GO, YEAH, THEY ALSO CAME
UP WITH THE FIRST PRICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A BIG
DEAL.
THIS COMEBACK KID THING IS
CRAZY.
MORE LIKE COME BACK TO LIFE KID.
I WAS UPSET, THOUGH.
BIDEN DID SIGN OFF ON THE FBI
RAID.
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS WIDELY
REPORTED.
IN HIS DEFENSE, HE THOUGHT HE
WAS SIGNING FOR AN AMAZON
PACKAGE.
HE'S LIKE, A PACKAGE FOR ME!
I HOPE IT'S NOT
AND THE NUCLEAR CODES THING TO
ME IS SUCH B.S. AND SO BIZARRE.
THEY CHANGE THE COLLEGE -- I DID
HEAR FROM A PRETTY GOOD SOURCE
THAT BIDEN'S NUCLEAR CODES, IT'S
00005, BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO FORGET YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Dana: KAT, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THE DEMOCRATS...
THEY VOTE WITH THEM 100% OF THE
TIME BUT THEY RUN ADS FOR THEIR
ELECTIONS SAYING I'M DISTANCING
FROM HIM?
>> I MEAN, HE'S ALSO DISTANCING
FROM EVERYONE.
THAT'S WHY I FEEL LIKE IT DOES
FEEL LIKE HE'S HAVING A COMEBACK
EVERY TIME WE SEE HIM.
BECAUSE WE DON'T SEE THEM VERY
OFTEN.
SO HE'S LIKE, WE DID IT.
HE SETS THE BAR FOR HIMSELF
VERY, VERY LOW.
HE MAKES IT UP THE STAIRS, WE
ARE LIKE, THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
HE GETS OUT A FULL SENTENCE WE
ARE LIKE, THIS GUY IS A STAR.
BECAUSE HE SETS THE BAR SO LOW
FOR HIMSELF!
SO EVERY DAY FEELS LIKE A
COMEBACK IF WE ACTUALLY KNOW
WHERE HE IS.
>> Dana: JONATHAN?
HOW ARE YOU?
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE HERE?
ARE YOU ON KUMBLE
>> NONE OF US SHOULD BE
COMPARABLE HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE
A FORMER PRESS SECRETARY FROM
GEORGE BUSH, FORMER PRIEST, WARM
EXECUTIVE COACH DOING A COMEDY
SHOW.
NONE OF US SHOULD BECOME THE
BALL WITH THAT.
BUT IT'S SO OBVIOUS THE
RIDICULOUS OF SO MUCH THAT'S
GOING ON IN THE WORLD THAT IT'S
FUN TO LAUGH AT, HONESTLY.
WE HAVE TO LAUGH AT IT.
IT'S GOOD TO LAUGH AT IT.
AT THE SAME TIME WE RECOGNIZE WE
HAVE A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE OF
TRUST IN OUR LEADERSHIP AND WE
ALL KNOW IT'S A VERY SERIOUS
THING AND IT STARTS WITH THE
PRESIDENCY.
IF WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO'S
REALLY NOT RUNNING ANYTHING AND
THEY GET A LOT OF STUFF DONE
WHEN HE IS NOT DOING ANYTHING,
THAT'S...
THAT'S A PRETTY SAD SITUATION
AND WE SEE THAT IN A LOT OF
PARTS OF OUR SOCIETY RIGHT NOW
AND I'M GLAD WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
>> Dana: REALLY QUICK.
HOW TO THE WORKING PEOPLE OF
ALASKA FEEL HAVING TO PAY OFF
THE STUDENT LOANS OF PEOPLE LIKE
AOC?
>> I HAVEN'T TALKED TO TONS OF
PEOPLE BUT I WOULD SAY IN
GENERAL NOT FANS.
YOU KNOW?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WAS TALKING TO SOMEBODY THE
OTHER DAY, I'M GOING TO SCHOOL
FOR THIS.
YOU GO TO REGULAR SCHOOL AND
THEN YOU GET A MASTERS OR YOU GO
TO A BACHELOR'S AND I LIKE
EVENTUALLY THE GOAL IS TO BE TO
HAVE LESS MONTHS TO LIVE THEN